buonasera a tutti
devo confidare una cosa prima di
iniziare che probabilmente ma non
diciamo dagli organizzatori che
probabilmente non ci ascoltano che se
avessi saputo che voi sareste stati così
tanti se avessi saputo che da in
streaming che stanno vedendo in più di
mille persone e se avessi saputo che
sarei dovuto entrare come dodicesima
speaker probabilmente non avrei
accettato l'invito ma ovviamente sto
scherzando perché voi siete fantastici e
sono veramente orgoglioso di poter
partecipare a questo the licks quindi
grazie davvero per l'invito
a proposito di futuro
io ho qualche giorno fa ho voluto ho
provato a fare un gioco che in realtà
non si è dimostrato poi neanche così
così divertente ho digitato sulla barra
di ricerca google il binomio italia
futuro i link e le pagine gli articoli a
cui sono stata rimandata hanno suscitato
in me ma credo in chiunque abbia un
minimo di sensibilità
un'espressione come questa
ho provato sgomento ho provato ho fatto
un urlo silenzioso soffocato ma comunque
molto potente come quello passato alla
storia e dipinto dal grande artista
munch
ho provato sgomento di fronte ad una
quasi inscalfibile ad una cruda quasi
unica possibile lettura di un paese il
nostro
completamente allo sbando
smarrito e senza possibilità di riscatto
un paese fermo stagnante in continua
recessione considerate che dal 2008 ad
oggi ci sono due milioni di posti di
lavoro in meno
meno di un cittadino su due è occupato e
oggi sono tanti troppi quei giovani
inattivi che non studiano e non cercano
lavoro i cosiddetti neet che vengono
etichettati con un bollino in fronte
proprio come si fa con un prodotto
qualunque su un nastro trasportatore
le aziende chiudono i negozi tirano giù
le saracinesche
e quelle imprese che tentano di tutto
pur di non dichiarare fallimento
delocalizzano in questo modo e lasciano
per la strada lasciano nello smarrimento
più totale
tutti quegli uomini e tutte quelle donne
che di fatto non erano solo operai e
dipendenti ma erano anima stessa
dell'impresa che hanno contribuito a far
crescere diventando parte di storia
dell'impresa stessa
i consumi calano la povertà cresce
aumentano le diseguaglianze economiche e
sociali e abbiamo welfare completamente
inesistente siamo il paese
dell'incertezza
siamo il paese dell'austerità mandato
che mi ha colpito più di ogni altro è
che siamo il paese più infelice del
mondo
non so se lo sapete
ma la 80 siamo il popolo meno contatto
del mondo l'ottanta per cento di noi si
ritiene insoddisfatto e mettiamo caso
che in questa calda in questa sala
lasciamo cento solo 9 di noi ritengono
di poter trovare un posto all'interno
della società un esempio di
rassegnazione di morte di morte
dell'ambizione di in totale incapacità
di sognare è per questo che i giovani
oggi i giovani come me oggi scappano e
quelli che restano si aggrappano ai
grandi ma senza prospettive senza
aspettative senza la voglia di potersi
costruire un futuro da soli siamo quelli
della generazione perduta come quella
raccontata da hemingway quando si
riferiva a tutti quei ragazzi che hanno
vissuto la propria giovinezza nel bel
mezzo della prima guerra mondiale io
credo che oggi non sia poi così diverso
io credo che oggi i ragazzi della mia
età i miei coetanei stanno vivendo la
propria giovinezza nel bel mezzo di un
altro conflitto
magari meno chiassoso ma comunque
spaventoso che è quello dell'it lismo
dopo essermi ripresa da una paralisi
facciale per aver imitato l'urlo di
munch mi sono posta però queste tre
domande
ma veramente l'italia solo questo
ma veramente noi italiani e il nostro
paese ma soprattutto i nostri figli ai
nostri nipoti non ha se non avranno un
futuro
ma soprattutto il futuro che appartiene
io non sono una veggente non sono una
cartomante non sono una maga con poteri
soprannaturali
ma sono una ragazza di 25 anni che si
sta costruendo il futuro con le proprie
mani in questo paese e che passa gran
parte del suo tempo su un trattore e
quelle mani in mezzo alla terra
e da scorpione ascendente ariete quale
fano ci sono in me vivono in me delle
grandi convinzioni di cui difficilmente
riuscirete a privarmi la prima
io sono sicura che dovremmo guardare
all'italia con occhi diversi
dovremmo essere in grado di cambiare
sguardo sul nostro paese
dovremo essere in grado di allontanarci
da quella foschia che accompagna la
considerazione che noi italiani abbiamo
di noi stessi del nostro paese e allora
scopriremo un paese che ce la fa
un paese che punta sui suoi talenti un
paese che punta sui suoi territori sulle
sue comunità sulle sue tradizioni sulle
sue conoscenze scopriremo un paese un
paese che non è vero essere senza futuro
a patto però che riparta da ciò che nel
mondo ci rende eccellenza la bellezza il
genio e la creatività e la qualità che
nel mondo è sinonimo di italia e che
trova il più alto riconoscimento la più
alta espressione forza nel nostro made
in italy
se sapessimo guardare all'italia con
occhi diversi ci accorgeremmo di giulia
giulia ha la stessa età anagrafica di
chi oggi viene considerato un cervello
in fuga
oggi giulia invece è rimasta e dopo una
laurea magistrale in architettura ha
deciso di aiutare la propria famiglia
portare avanti un progetto di
agricoltura sociale oggi giulia in
veneto accoglie bambini disabili ragazze
i genitori in difficoltà all'interno
della propria azienda
alcuni di questi bambini hanno iniziato
a parlare gli adolescenti che erano
considerati ormai persi hanno ritrovato
la fiducia in se stessi la motivazione
alla vita e al lavoro alcune famiglie
sono rinate oggi giulia che è rimasta in
italia in veneto aiuta un sacco di
persone a ritrovare la fiducia in se
stesse
crea posti di lavoro genera occupazione
e ricchezza
se sapessimo guardare all'italia con
occhi diversi ci accorgeremo di luigi
luigi è nato cresciuto in calabria in
quella calabria che troppi guardano da
lontano per paura di sporcarsi
luigi invece è orgoglioso di essere
calabrese e ad oriolo calabro produce un
amaro con i suoi ulivi di cui lui stesso
si prende cura e con una ricetta antica
della nonna rimasta nascosta e chiusano
un libro per tanto troppo tempo
oggi luigi lavora con i migliori chef
stellati internazionali
oggi luigi esporta il suo prodotto in
tutto il mondo e con esso l'immagine di
una calabria che sa produrre e creare
occupazione ma soprattutto oggi luigi ha
reso la sua nonna la donna per vogliosa
del mondo
se sapessimo guardare all'italia con
occhi diversi
ci accorgeremo di francesco i suoi amici
tutti provenienti da mondi diversi in un
giorno hanno deciso di investire e
rischiare
oggi francesco i suoi amici producono
una birra artigianale a km zero hanno
trasformato il loro sogno in un'attività
economica remunerativa
un'attività che mette in connessione la
voglia e la grinta di un gruppo di
ragazzi che ha deciso di costruirsi il
proprio futuro con la storia e
l'identità storica del territorio senese
oggi francesco i suoi amici coltivano
l'orzo nelle colline toscane
oggi francesco e i suoi amici hanno
aperto un birrificio in una birreria
dove lavorano 10 dipendenti tutti under
giulia luigi francesco i suoi amici sono
solo una piccola rappresentanza di quel
futuro possibile che oggi tanti ragazzi
come loro e tanti ragazzi come me si
stanno costruendo nel nostro paese che
non vogliamo abbandonare
oggi francesco oggi giulia luigi
francesco i suoi amici per rappresentano
i giovani di coldiretti quei giovani che
stanno investendo in un nuovo modello di
sviluppo che ci racconta di un'italia
che fa primeggiare nel mondo di
un'italia che primeggia per efficienza
ambientale per meno co2 e meno rifiuti
prodotti dalle imprese di un'italia che
accoglie più turisti statunitensi
canadesi australiani
brasiliani di ogni altro di un paese che
vanta più di 120 prodotti agroalimentari
unici al mondo per la loro qualità
giulia luigi francesco e i suoi amici
stanno costruendo il proprio futuro
sulla terra sulla pietra più solida
concreta e così alta da poter guardare
lontano che è la terra e qui risiede la
mia seconda convinzione che nei nostri
territori inimitabili nel nostro cibo
identitario sicuro e democratico che nel
rispetto delle comunità nella dignità
delle persone e nel rispetto
dell'ambiente del lavoro risiede quella
strada che noi tutti stiamo cercando per
poter dire a noi stessi ai nostri figli
e ai nostri nipoti che l'italia un
futuro
giulia luigi francesco ei suoi amici ci
insegnano che non dobbiamo bendarsi gli
occhi aspettando che qualcuno faccia di
noi quello che meglio crede ci insegna
che non bisogna cercare modelli altrove
altri modelli alternativi possibili da
poter imitare ci insegnano per con
determinazione che con passione con
grinta audacia pazienza e un pizzico di
follia ognuno di noi si può costruire un
futuro in questa meravigliosa italia ci
insegnano che ognuno di noi deve essere
responsabile di se stessi ma con sempre
uno sguardo rivolto agli altri affinché
ciò che vi bene faccio per me di buono
faccia per il mio paese ma soprattutto
ci insegnano la mia terza convinzione
che il futuro appartiene a coloro che
credono nella bellezza dei propri sogni
la nostra italia è piena di sogni e di
sognatori e di questi se questi
sognatori ci dimostrano ogni giorno come
questi sogni possono diventare realtà
coldiretti li scopre li racconta e li
sostiene da anni e continuerà a farlo
con un breve video ve li voglio
presentare affinché ognuno di noi questa
sala se non possa credere se non possa
credere ma almeno sperare come me che
l'italia si investe su ciò che di buono
la nostra terra ad offrire e su una
nuova economia fatta di persone di
socialità di storie viabilità di cultura
e di conoscenza al futuro ed è più roseo
di quello che possiamo immaginare
grazie a tutti e buona visione